- En d d d d d d d d d d d d d .
30 minutes avant le défilé
coorororatif, la foule
se faisait encore attendre. s s.
J'aurais pensé qu'il y aurait eu
auauaucoup plus de gens.
- J'aurais pensé qu'on aurait eu
de la difficulté à se mettre- -s
de pnnnnnnes ont finalement
suivi les militaires et les
policiers le long du parcours.
Ailleurs au pays, les
commémorations ont parfois eu
lieu devant des chaises vides,
comme à Windsor, en Ontario,
ou en présence d'une foule p
en Colombie-Britannique.
Sous le soleil ou sous la e,e,e,
ceux qui se sont déplacés
- Je l'ai toujours vue
comme un symboli e e e e e e e .
- Je pense quand même que
ça fait partie de l'histoire.
Même si on est francophones,
on vit quand même parmi...
un dan m m milieu où la reine
est importante.nt lnt lnt lnt là
par attachement à la reine
ÉlisabeI,I,I, et moins
à la monarchie.
- C'est plutôt en
représentait pour moi
comme une femme.
(coup de canon)
- Le Canada est le seul pays du
à la reine lors d'une cérémonie
officielle, tenue en présence
600 dignitaires à la cathédrale
Christ Church d'Ottawa.
GINETTE RENO, auteure-interprète
♪ Ceux qui s'en vont ♪
♪ Ceux qui nous laissent ♪
L'ancien premier ministre
Brian Mulroney a souligné
l'engagement de la souveraine
et le fait français au Canada.
BRIAN MULRONEY, ancien premier
ministre du Canada (1984-1993)
- Son respect inestimable
pour le rôle unique jouéssssssss
l'avancement du Québec moderne.
RUFUS WAINWRIGHT
auteur-compositeur-interprète
♪ Hallelujah ♪
PABLO RODRIGUEZ, ministre
- Elle avait un attachement
profond pour le Canada,
pour les Canadiens.
Et à travers ses 70 années
de règne, elle a représen t t ts
les bons et les mauvais moments.
Alors nous, on est là
pour la remercier.
PIERRE POILIEVRE, chef,
- Nos pensées sont avec
sa famille, et nous sommes trè
reconnaissants de son service...
au Royaume-Uni,
mais aussi au Canada.
Nouveau Parti démocratique
- Même à la fin dededededededed.
♪ Hallelujah ♪
- Au début d'un nouveau règne
où Charles III devra faire
sa place, celui d'Élisabeth II
restera, pour beaucoup
de dévouement et de dignité.
♪ Hallelujah ♪
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Loua,a,a,a,a,a,a,a,a,a,a,aw